indeed
um I want to move on to the lovely topic
of Consciousness
um we've had many folks on the show who
strongly believe that computationalism
is false which is to say that you know
it it can't it can't be created in
silico and I just wondered how you
thought you know progress in theoretical
Neuroscience can shape our understanding
of the nature of Consciousness or or
qualia but do you think that
Consciousness could be created
artificially
yep
go on
[Laughter]
please I have been known to refer to
this as the c word
um yeah so Consciousness is uh yeah it's
definitely a fraught topic
um I I don't understand the failure of
imagination that for some reason silicon
and electrical currents can't realize a
function that can be realized in
you know electrochemical systems that
are more carbon based
I I just I don't understand the
intuition why why there has to be
something so special about one
particular implementation
so if we take Consciousness to be
something which is essentially
functional which I think we have every
reason to believe it is you know not
every carbon-based life form is
conscious uh if you think it is then we
have a whole other bunch of things to
talk about
um but if we don't think they all are
right then I don't see
any reason to think that they can only
they can be right uh and so I I exactly
how people come down on the horns of
that dilemma is really interesting you
know it's people like John Cyril just
embrace it and like yep if it's not
biological stuff it can't possibly have
understanding and can't be conscious
but from my perspective you know I just
don't understand at all
how to convince myself of that there
seems to be no empirical fact I can
appeal to and I can feel to lots of
other empirical facts that suggest many
of the interesting functions that we see
in biological systems can be replicated
in non-biological systems
so
right now I think the preponderance of
evidence is in favor of
being able to have Consciousness and
non-biologically based
physical substrates
yeah it's such a difficult topic to
discuss and good because so was talking
about understanding in Louisville yeah
but yeah yeah yes I'm not entirely sure
off the top of my head whether it
whether he would say that Consciousness
couldn't exist in in silicone it's more
the sense that John Searle in the room
didn't understand Chinese without the
phenomenal experience or whatever but um
yeah it's it's really interesting
because the problem with Consciousness
is there's no there's no consciousness
meter right we can measure function
Dynamics and behavior but Consciousness
is is kind of like in in The Ether so so
to speak I mean I just wondered if if
could you kind of formalize what you
think it is and how it emerges
um
right sure if I had to guess uh
essentially I think it is a complex
dynamical system
um self-monitoring right so I think we
have and there's all kinds of evidence
that different parts of the brain are
sensitive to what other parts of the
brain are doing are sensitive to errors
that we make in speaking or motor
control
um you know are
um we have a lot of hierarchical
structure in the way that our biological
system is put together and so something
like you know a sufficiently deep
hierarchical controller I think is
what's going on when we start having
that system able to report about its own
States right so it's really it's really
an issue of just how the information is
flowing through the system and so when
you're down at the level of bugs where
you've got these ganglia that are
controlling the legs pretty much
independently from the brain which is
about the same has the same number of
neurons as each of the controllers in
the legs then there's just nothing there
to be doing this kind of monitoring and
so there's no conscious experience
there's no what it's like there's
nothing right there's nothing looking at
the neural activity in the right kind of
way but as we move to mammalian brains
then you know in all of these kinds of
brains we find very sophisticated
sort of self-monitoring uh in some sort
of way which eventually allows us to
report
like people do
yeah I mean trauma is famously argued um
like he's our property dualist and that
is you know the only strongly emergent
phenomenon in the universe so not
directly deducible for many truths in
the low-level domain and all of that
stuff but but you know it couldn't help
but get the feeling of Charmers that
you're left thinking especially with his
philosophical zombies argument that
what's the point you know what what
purpose does Consciousness solve if it's
completely separate to all the other
parts of the system I mean what purpose
do you think it solves
oh so why would you want to self-monitor
there's a million reasons right so this
a massive Improvement in robustness
right uh so your ability to identify
errors before the environment tells you
sort of severely punishing you uh or
even interlocutors so have you know
being in a social group where catching
your own social errors before somebody
else does can be critical
um you know giving you sort of levels of
um sophistication in uh
predicting the you know future States
based on past States I mean all these
things are going to be dependent on your
ability to integrate information across
many different systems and that
integration is the kind of thing that
you know sort of I think concurrently
happens with the uh the monitoring stuff
right so yeah yeah I I understand that
but I think you're still talking about
the Dynamics which is like the
microscopic behavior and you get so I I
mean I I can I can go along with what
you're saying I think it seems plausible
to me that you have those Dynamics and
then you have this macroscopic weird
thing called Consciousness emerge but
but that thing doesn't seem to be doing
anything
what do you mean so it's doing things in
the sense that so
so I will admittedly struggle with the
notion that there is something which is
consciousness which is independent from
uh the brain or something like you know
when people say I don't know if you're
familiar with Dan Dennis Quine and
qualia right but a reasonable believer
in this idea that sure we can make up
properties which you know are
non-introspection introspectable or
measurable or what have you but we're
just making the properties up at that
point like we don't have any reason to
think that they are real existing things
and we can talk about them we can fool
ourselves through the way that we
structure language into reifying them
making them seem as real as other things
which actually are but yeah things like
you know the what it is like independent
of the person having the experience of
what it is like like is what like
these are you know these are just
conceptually problematic for my my
perspective so yeah I will always think
about conscious experience as being uh
something being had by a system by a
physical system right and I don't think
we have any evidence to the contrary
ours I'm aware yes I mean I must agree I
mean intuitively I'd I I am a
physicalist and it does sound like an
affront on physicalism I mean traumas is
a materialist he he has a way of arguing
that it still is but um let's bring in
in embodiment so um you know this is
really really interesting right there's
there's this concept of um embodied
Consciousness and I just wondered like
to what extent do you think that
um embodiment is is a you know a
required uh component of consciousness
that's a tricky one so
um
how could you have a disembodied
Consciousness it counts as disembodied
Consciousness right so is it somebody
you know like floating above themselves
on the operating table is that
disembodied participants
um because my suspicion is that it in
some ways it is in some ways it isn't
right so it's embodied Consciousness in
the sense that the person having the
conscious experience has a body
um but it's disembodied in the sense
that they feel like they are observing
something uh from a perspective which
you can't have from within the body but
you know people are are reasonably good
at actually taking on perspectives that
they aren't experiencing in the moment
so but does that count as disembodied I
mean I don't know and they are maybe the
more important thing is like I don't
think you would
have the kinds of conscious experience
that we do with nobody but again I'm
just speculating about some untested
untestable uh state of the world right
so our bodies play a significant role in
determining the kinds of conscious
experience that we have that seems
reasonable okay but we are traveling at
100 miles an hour into you know this
mind-body problem you know going back to
to Descartes and it's all about the the
relationship between mental States and
physical States so what do you think
that relationship is exactly I mean for
example I can I can dream and I can
imagine lots of things in my mind most
of those are deducible from things I've
experienced and you could argue some of
them are not but what's what's that
relationship
I mean the things we call mental states
are physical States right that's that's
my that's the relationship I don't I
don't think it's too complicated the
mind is the brain or the mind is in the
brain mind this actually this I think
this is always a little bit funny what
kinds of words people pick to to say
what the mind brain relation is but yeah
you know ultimately they're one in the
same and we can take different
perspectives on the same physical system
giving rise to you know different ways
of describing those physical systems so
when we talk about mental States
I think we're often averaging over or
you know picking out a variety of or
clumping together a variety of brain
States right
um which is
fine it's a very reasonable thing we do
we do it for all kinds of physical
systems all the time
um it's interesting in the case of the
mental and physical is that you you
can't step outside of the mental right
so you can you know you can't imagine
some other system which is interacting
you know like one example is lightning
right so you know is lightning
um
identical to the ionic charges that are
flowing through the the atmosphere so I
I would say yes yeah I think they're
identical
um and then someone says well just a
minute you can't you can't like measure
that flash or without Consciousness
right well you can't you're relying on
your mental state to make that
physicalist identity claim and the
answer is well yeah I guess you know you
are I can't I can't make any claims
where I completely get outside of my own
uh you know subjective experience so it
just gets more and more murky when we're
trying to talk about
things like that physicalist identity in
the case of lightning but now we're
talking about the mental States
themselves which we also can't get
outside of so I think it gets it gets
hard to think about but I don't think
it's inconsistent right I think you can
definitely hold this View and uh like I
feel like I do and it makes perfect
sense and can I prove it to you no can
you prove the opposite to me no and
that's that's where my patients with
philosophy gets thin interesting I love
I love this concept of subjective
experience it seems quite important and
um I just wonder whether you could
Define it because presumably you think
an agent has an internal representation
and and that is its subjective
experience and there's some kind of
asymmetry between its representation and
what can be
sorry that's Siri there's some um
asymmetry between its representation and
what can be conveyed to other agents
yes I will say that I mean I would be I
would not identify uh my internal
representations with experience I think
we have internal mental representations
which we don't experience that we don't
know about right there's subjective
subjectivity it has limits into what it
can have access to
um um and that's part of the reason why
I agree with the second part of your
statement which is that we can typically
only partially describe our internal
representations to others right
um and taking that perspective and
trying to communicate it is always going
to be limited right because we don't
have perfect access to all of our
internal representations in a way that
we can yeah yes and that that asymmetry
seems to be the core point that even so
was talking about that there's always a
richer representation inside than which
can be conveyed outside but I'm pleased
forgive me
um the Indulgence but I would love to
get your take on Free Will and an agency
I mean even with agency what makes us an
agent and do we actually get to choose
our own actions are we are we autonomous
practically yes
to me this is like the infinity question
right so okay
um you know and and it may be in a
surprisingly direct way so I think
people are chaotic dynamical systems
chaotic dynamical systems are not
practically predictable right so and
assuming infinite Precision of course
um and so I think when it comes to the
question of Free Will are we determined
like are we are we deterministic or not
well chaotic dynamical systems are
deterministic and unpredictable and so
you're one of those at worst and maybe
maybe you have actual Free Will whatever
that but it doesn't matter there it's in
it's indistinguishable from the
perspective of any social structure any
legal system you know any desire to hold
people responsible for actions and all
that kind of thing so so ultimately that
you know makes the question of free will
one
which is uh
I'll say as interesting as some of these
questions about Consciousness which to
me just means unanswerable and sound
interesting
yeah
fascinating and even then there's a
scale dependence but even at the human
scale we're sufficiently chaotic that
you would argue that yeah it's very
difficult to predict okay I mean just
before we move off philosophy do you
think there are any like important
philosophical questions that theoretical
new restaurants can help us answer
yeah many I mean this is uh you know so
literally my my trajectory has been
doing an engineering degree go get a PhD
in philosophy of mind and then do
theoretical neuroscience and the
theoretical Neuroscience is literally in
my PhD thesis and I think that uh more
of that can happen and in that instance
you know I was looking at questions of
what are mental representations can we
give stories what is misrepresentation
mental misrepresentation how do you map
neural States so uh onto psychological
States so you know I I use this term
neurosemantics in place of something
like psychosemantics which is trying to
be you know much more clear about
exactly the kinds of questions you were
just asking me about
um and yeah I do think that this
interaction can continue so we can learn
things about
how to talk about particular
philosophical questions about
representation and uh and knowledge and
understanding and so on
um in in the context of what are our
best theories of understanding how
brains function you know what what
mathematical properties do we have or
not have which ones are important which
ones aren't is it does it matter to take
into account finite resource constraints
um if we think in terms of continuous
versus discrete States is that going to
change how we answer questions about
knowledge and certainty and all these
kinds of things and I think the answer
is generally yes you know these can have
uh lots of impact that these being the
answers to the theoretical Neuroscience
questions can have lots of impact in the
way that we would address a wide variety
of philosophical questions absolutely